That wasn't you was it steven what the hell was
that welcome back everyone this will be my full
marvel moon knight episode 6 finale video there
are a whole bunch of easter eggs so we'll break
it down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
even though this is the moon knight finale we're
gonna get another big marvel series really soon
i'll be doing videos for that we have the obi-wan
kenobi episodes that are going to be dropping in a
couple weeks too i'll be doing full episode videos
for that next but careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet we'll be talking about
everything i'll just start at the beginning we'll
go through shot by shot talking about easter eggs
wtf moments because they did have some big reveals
and they obviously end on a big teaser that
tells you what's happening with moon knight next
but just starting with the episode title it was
called gods and monsters which is a reference to
literally the gods fighting each other like
Khonshu vs ammit and the hippo goddess also
helping them out they all look like physical
monsters like literally monsters walking around
because the way their bodies exist but they're
also doing monstrous things like inside the mcu
ammit wants to go full minority report killing
everyone who will potentially do evil in the
future but also consciou on the side is no better
he's doing all these really underhanded things
it's just he says he doesn't want to kill people
until they do bad things but on the side he's
doing all these other really terrible things all
the monstrous acts that arthur harrow accused
him of doing were not lies and you also have the
people like jake lockley doing monstrous things
killing a whole bunch of people doing terrible
things for meet my friend jake lockley so both the
gods and the people are no better than monsters
one of the big changes is there's no cold open
in the episode they just start with that regular
marvel phase four intro but this time they use the
pop song which is a classic version of end of the
rainbow by earl grant and the song is all about
finding gold finding the end of this story but the
story continuing on it's meant to be a metaphor
for moon knight dying in the previous episode but
his story not ending because it's also referenced
to the end of the episode with jake lockley
showing up whistling and then killing arthur
harrow for khonshu and them continuing to be moon
knight issues that jake lockley is now in control
of the body some of you probably figured out what
was going on a little bit quicker at the end of
the episode when he showed up in the hospital
in that post-credit scene like that looks like
jake lockley is he's speaking spanish and then
he actually turns around in the front of the limo
as the driver like jake lockley was a cab driver
speaking spanish and they confirmed that it is him
everyone waved to jake lockley i know there's
a lot of questions about the way they ended
the episode with them in the mind space and
them trapped in the room them being bound up
so i will explain that when we get to that part of
the episode a lot of the ending of the episode is
khonshu messing with their head playing tricks on
them with the help of jake lockley who is now in
control of the body but the actual opening scene
is arthur harrow's men taking his body out of the
water in a flashback so we're actually seeing what
happened previously like right after they shot him
they take ammit's stone prison so they can go
back to the great pyramid and free her after
they've taken care of most of the other avatars
i'll explain why they did that too in a second
there was a very specific order that things had to
happen in during the episode so that it wouldn't
cause more problems for arthur harrow but most
of what we saw during last week's episode with
them inside the mind space and sort of like this
holding area of the afterlife before they went
to the duwod time passes differently in this
version of the afterlife so it only seems like
a ton of time went by i did a big multiverse
video a little while ago kind of explaining the
difference between all the different versions
of the afterlife it's basically an alternate
dimension kind of like the astral plane where
the mind the soul exists separately from the body
so the way they perceive time is very different
from the way that time passes in the normal world
but when arthur harrow leans down and tells marc
spector's body that whoever else might be in there
sorry for doing this it's a reference to jake
lockley who we finally meet at the end of the
episode r.i.p arthur harrow they could always
surface other personalities inside there inside
the comics the only other real personality they
haven't done yet is the actual separate mr knight
personality but the way they played it on the tv
show is that just steven grant wearing a version
of the moon knight costume in the comics it's
meant to be a completely separate personality
and they're like five total the only weird thing
about this early part of the episode where layla's
trying to follow arthur harrow back to the great
pyramid and kill him is that she's able to hide
herself from him even though she's like right
there like you think he'd turn around and be like
oh you're clearly just layla just hiding inside
that mask there it was funny to see tarot try to
talk to her through all the different dead bodies
of the egyptian military that he was killing him
and he does go full obi-wan on them too papers
you don't need any of our papers you don't need
to see his identification we don't need to see his
identification they try to explain most of how all
this different cosmic power works that the gods
are wielding in the way their different abilities
work how they gain more power there were a lot of
people that were complaining about the way they
portrayed the avatars during episode three like
why was he able to deceive them so easily and
they're now just kind of figuring things out like
we detected something does that mean that ammit is
coming back wait a minute why is she coming back
like they're just figuring things out right now
you think with all that god tier power they
would figure this out a little bit sooner
like i said one of the reasons why that is because
most of the gods are pretty lazy and only really
worry about their own purview even Khonshu got
really pissed off at the rest of their pantheon
the rest of the any of their ruling council
saying that they've gotten way too decadent
in this pocket dimension that they were currently
living in called the overvoid these specific gods
that are part of this pantheon when they left
earth they basically said goodbye to humanity
even though they keep avatars there to kind of
watch what's actually happening they don't really
care about what's actually happening that's why
they didn't get involved with the snap or thanos
avengers infinity war avengers in-game or any of
that stuff that's why when we get to thor love
and thunder gore won't totally be wrong trying to
kill some of these gods off like some of them are
pretty terrible everyone getting ready to post
your gore was right memes like it started with
thanos was right memes after avengers end game
they even had a joke about that in hawkeye it's
gonna be the same thing but for gore after thor
loving thunder comes out but the big reason why
they have arthur harrow kill all the other avatars
before he releases ammit inside this special place
is so that they can't stop him because the other
guys are really powerful and they could wield that
power through their avatars but if he kills the
avatars then that basically sidelines the other
gods for at least a little while they release
ammit the cg for her was pretty good she has
this really feminine pretty looking crocodile face
like if you could make a crocodile looking pretty
there was a lot of jokes about this when alligator
loki debuted on the loki's series the showrunner
told the concept artist when they were trying to
conceive alligator loki please make us a loki with
beautiful looking eyes but alligator loki looked
more like an actual alligator just wearing a loki
costume ammit is more like tawereth the hippo
goddess like this anthropomorphized version of
a crocodile face with a humanoid body and just to
be clear she is a crocodile alligator loki was an
alligator completely different species even though
they look kind of similar the whole thing between
her and arthur harrow is that she says that she's
going to kill him eventually like i'm just holding
on this temporarily you will eventually be judged
because of all the terrible stuff that you've done
and that you will do issues that she doesn't trust
perfectly balance avatars anymore because of what
alexander the great did betraying her because of
what she planned to do going full minority report
the funny thing about that as bad as she seems
at least she's being honest about it whereas
khonshu is actually tricking marc specter
and steven grant oh i'll totally let you go
your contract is done but that doesn't mean that
i free the contract of all the other personalities
that are inside of you potentially it's just
a way for khonshu to be even worse somehow
than ammit like ammit was very open about what she
was trying to do even though it was also very bad
the whole thing with his eyes glowing when she
laid hands on him was them forming an official
contract in him becoming her full avatar gaining
her full power and they also explained the way
she exists here inside the mcu is a little bit
different remember the whole idea is that she's
supposed to exist fully inside the mcu whereas
the other gods transferred their essence to this
pocket dimension kind of like odin transferred to
valhalla layla as predicted follows tarouette's
plan frees khonshu who remarks on marc's death
and even though they end on that twist with him
just using jake lockley who is still the same body
as marc spector steven grant he does true to word
offer layla to become his next avatar like hey
you know you could totally gain all this power
which of course she refuses because the
whole thing is that she becomes tarouwet's
temporary quote-unquote temporary avatar although
that's a whole other thing too like temporary
could turn out to be a much longer period than
you think remember a lot of these gods are very
misleading one of the many reasons why gore the
god butcher is going around killing all them they
kind of clarify how ammit's power is going to work
how they're judging people because you saw some of
them start to die when they were stuck in the
afterlife at the end of last week's episode she
confirms that they're going to start with egypt
first and then they're going to do the rest of
the world then it'd be the rest of the galaxy then
the rest of the universe then eventually she would
become theoretically as powerful as the infinity
gauntlet when she consumed enough souls they also
clarify the effect too like you actually see the
souls as they die coming into her body making her
bigger and bigger more and more powerful it's kind
of like khonshu becoming more powerful under the
light of the full moon because he is the egyptian
god of the moon like a lot of his powers are tied
to the phases of the moon that's why he turns
it from night to day at the end of the episode
so that he will become more powerful and marc
spector steven grant will become more powerful
if your version of moon knight really what that
amounts to is that you're just stronger faster you
heal faster like all your regular abilities just
get a big boost to them but he still does have a
measure of his abilities during the daylight it's
just that he can't fly like he did at the night
he's not quite that powerful although technically
he wasn't really flying it was more like gliding
inside the egyptian afterlife we see marc spector
and steven grant as expected tarawick kind of
explains what's going on to marc and he turns down
their version of heaven so to speak to go save
steven grant like of course they're not gonna
get rid of all the personalities this is them
just doing more of the comics with the different
personas coming to an agreement with each other
realizing that they need each other to be a more
complete superhero it's just they're starting with
the relationship between steven grant and marc
spector eventually the same thing will happen like
a version of this with them and jake lockley as
well in the future like even though jake lockley
seems like a pretty terrible person and super
stabby eventually the three of them will come
to an arrangement and when we see ammit start
fighting khonshu when they're small size like
obviously they grow really huge at the end of
the episode but part of the reason why she seems
so much more powerful than him is because she
has so many more followers than konshu does and
she's been consuming so many more souls along the
way all the gods in the mcu have vastly different
power levels like not all gods are created equal
there are greater gods lesser gods mid-level gods
but the more followers a god gains the more power
they draw from them the more powerful they become
but also they added this modifier to ammit in the
mcu explaining that the more soul she consumes is
part of this process of them being judged and sent
to the afterlife the more powerful she becomes
whereas way fewer people believe in Khonshu right
now and it's not even the light of the full moon
yet but that is why he brings out the light of
the full moon at the end of the episode so that
it will even the scales between them a little
bit when he also says he chooses obliteration
over mercy it's also a reference to gore the god
butcher and thor love and thunder gore using the
necro sword to utterly obliterate the essence of
all gods their spirits too like when odin dies
this is odin's spirit it still lives on it just
transfers to another dimension of valhalla that
they believe in because the afterlife you go to is
actually just an alternate dimension based on your
own belief system as they explained previously
but like gore for instance can use the necrosore
to utterly obliterate their living essence as well
too so they'll be permadead it sounds like during
their fight here in the episode they're explaining
that gods can do that to other gods too probably
the same thing with really powerful cosmic beings
like the celestials would be powerful enough to
obliterate one of the other mcu gods which is
another reason why you don't see a lot of the mcu
gods going after the celestials we also just saw
the living tribunal in one of the doctor strange 2
trailers the living tribunal is like one of the
most powerful beings inside the marvel universe
next to the one above all so the living tribunal
would also have enough power to obliterate mcu
gods they explained the reason why they're able
to escape through the gates of osiris resurrecting
basically it's like a visual representation of
them resurrecting inside the body is because as
tarawest says osiris basically gives them an
assist is basically the god himself actually
helping them out the other way they're able to do
this is khonshu can actually physically resurrect
them as well too that's one of his powers like in
the comics moon knight dies many different times
and each time Khonshu just resurrects him again
like it's no big deal but the way they played
this in the episode Khonshu actually reforms the
bargain with him again when he resurrects in the
body and that's how he gets the costume back the
powers and gets rid of the bullet wounds this is a
bit of a callback to episode one when he said okay
the minute this is done or the minute we die our
contract is done because remember he did offer
for layla to become his next avatar he wouldn't
have done that if marc spector was still alive so
that's why he has to reform the contract with him
when he's resurrecting did that funny moment with
steven grant trying to form a bargain with khonshu
about letting them go but like i said this is all
just foreshadowing for jake lockley like okay i'll
let the two of you go but he did not say any
theoretical other personality inside their body
the way the khonshu explains that they trap on me
forever by binding her to arthur harrow's body is
because she exists fully in the mcu right now so
they need to basically transfer her into spirit
essence inside the body of a mortal and the way
the series explains the rules for how this works
on a cosmic level is that when arthur harrow dies
it will force her to leave the mcu dimension the
same way the other gods did and transfer to the
overvoid this pocket dimension where the other
gods themselves have their full power and can
just trap her for the rest of all time or at least
until gor the god butcher shows up and kills all
them issues that khonshu doesn't finish the job so
to speak like kill him and then make her transfer
her essence to this pocket dimension until the end
of the episode they have that funny moment with
layla becoming the hippo goddesses avatar who
seems like she's just happy to be on the team like
she's probably this happy with anybody who would
ever form a contract with her we're gonna have so
much fun i'm gonna give you the coolest looking
costume ever so when layla comes back in a future
marvel production it's just a way for her to have
powers too anybody even old man captain america
any of the other avengers that are still alive
they could also form contracts with the gods and
get some of these extra powers on top of what they
already have now you're all wondering if that
means that thor could also select an avatar too
but the whole idea is that when layla becomes
the avatar of the hippo goddess she gains most of
the same powers that marc spector has but because
each god is sort of the god of something different
they have slightly different attributes slightly
different powers some of the other abilities are
different from each other but like she has the
same ability to fly like he does it's just that
her gliding system is a little bit different
i did like the scene of the actress who plays
layla acting out both parts like she was acting as
the hippo goddess using the body but also acting
as layla herself reacting to everything then like
i said konshu changes the day to night so that he
will become more powerful and thus marc spector
will become more powerful we see him gliding he
could have done that before just as long as it was
night but he does have his powers during the day
just not as powerful during the day that's because
Khonshu is the god of the moon along with being
the mcu god of vengeance then they have their
giant battle royale gods vs gods and avatars vs
avatars the reason why they have to tag team him
why it takes two of them to defeat him is because
ammit as we see becomes more powerful than Khonshu
because she's consuming so many more souls than
Khonshu and has so many more followers and like i
said layla has a lot of the same abilities as marc
spector like enhanced strength speed she can fly
just like him she also has the healing factor too
like she uses her wings to block a lot of the
bullets in blast she could probably soak them
just like moon knight did in previous episodes
but it would hurt a lot like they still feel it
it's just they heal really quickly it's a lot like
the way wolverine's healing factor works like he
heals almost instantly but every time he feels it
when you stab him when you shoot him then the way
they play this is that ammit has Khonshu dead to
rights she's more powerful if he dies then they'll
lose power so they're getting weaker and weaker as
arthur harrow gets ready to actually kill them and
try to judge them using the staff in their life
being threatened that much is what brings out jake
lockley and he's obviously the one who defeats
all them killing all the randos around them
that wasn't you who was it steven not a chance
mate so it seems like jake lockley only surfaces
when they've been in mortal danger or they feel
like their life is threatened in a really serious
way like we could die at any second now and the
way they play this too is that jake lockley's
moon knight costume when he's in control of the
body looks just like the regular moon knight
costume that's why layla is like wait a minute
what happened there because he looked the exact
same but he was killing all these people most of
you could probably detect though that when they
started chanting it was the same process that the
gods used on Khonshu in the previous episode to
bind him issues that they bind ammit to arthur
harrow's body instead of binding her to another
stone figure like they did before the ironic thing
about marc spector rejecting conscious orders to
kill arthur harrow is that it was earlier in the
episodes that arthur harrow told him that he did
not have to obey Khonshu it was arthur harrow who
said you don't have to do what he says but just
to explain what happens here because it seems like
Khonshu frees them from their contract and you see
this big bright light but then they wake up inside
the mental hospital what's happening here is a
combination of a regular old time jump in Khonshu
playing tricks on their mind making a bargain
separately with jake lockley without them knowing
about it so what happens during the time jump here
even though it's kind of implied they basically
lose the powers because the contract goes away
they're technically free temporarily they take
arthur harrow's body back to a mental hospital
so they can get treatment he gets drugged up so
that he basically doesn't cause any trouble it's
meant to be an ironic twist for them winding up in
the mind space hospital in the previous episodes
but the reason why it jumps immediately to them
inside the mind space hospital just talking to
this fake version of arthur harrow just realizing
hey this isn't real we can do whatever we want we
can leave any time we want that's actually taking
place during a completely different time period
it's just they've been blacking out not knowing
what's been happening and the reason why they're
bound is because now it's jake lockley in control
of the body who's been binding them up the same
way that they've been bound before during episode
one when marc spector was the one trying to
control the body manipulate steven grant just
talking about the post credit scene too because
obviously is jake lockley showing up on conscious
orders to kill arthur harrow they even have the
rubber duck which is meant to be a reference to
the fake version of arthur harrow it's a bit of a
meta reference i think the way this was supposed
to happen is that Khonshu frees them from the
contract they take arthur harrow in their just
regular old human body with layla's help to a
mental hospital then a little bit of time goes by
something happens to trigger jake lockley coming
out of the body then conscious appears to him
forms a new contract with him and they worked
together to hide that from both marc spector
and steven grant in his while jake lockley is
in control that he tells him okay now you go back
and you kill arthur harrow so when they wake up
from the mental hospital at the end of the episode
like oh no here we go again it's the same thing
and there's two goldfish now this is an ambiguous
time jump forward at some point in the future and
during all the dead periods where they don't
remember things that's when jake lockley's been in
control they've been doing stuff for Khonshu when
he kicks the stretcher you notice on the sign over
here on the left it also says Sienkiewicz that's
for bill Sienkiewicz a really famous marvel artist
who drew on the moon knight title for a long time
the license plate on their car says spectre it's
a reference to marc spector like it's the same
person just a different personality Khonshu
when he's speaking to arthur harris says you know
why would i ever let him go when there's all the
personalities i would need inside that body the
other funny thing too is that Khonshu is actually
wearing a suit just like he wore in the comics
it's the exact same type of suit that steven
grant was wearing the psycho colonel sanders suit
when he was using the powers of moon knight they
also played that frank sinatra song over them
driving away about him never letting a lover go
being a reference to konshoot never letting marc
spector steven grant's body go because they just
have more personalities that he can form bargains
with like i said all the bad things that arthur
harrow said happened to him came true for marc
spector as well and steven grant he told them that
Khonshu was never going to let them go and true
to his word Khonshu is never going to let them go
but what's probably going to happen next is that
moonite will either come back during the werewolf
by night halloween special because in his original
appearance moon knight just showed up as a villain
on the orders of someone else to kill werewolf by
night they could just have jake lockley the stabby
one trying to kill werewolf by night on conscious
orders because it also seems like they're heading
up to some darker team up like a midnight suns
type of team up moon knight also might come
back during the blade movie next year too they
did tease him crossing over with avengers 5 and
other big projects but they haven't said anything
about them doing moon knight season 2 i think the
idea is that he probably show up in other people's
series and movies before they do moon eye season 2
if they ever do it but if there are any big easter
eggs in the episode that you spotted that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments or if you have big questions about
what's going on with the gods how everything
works they also just released a new obi-wan
kenobi trailer video so i'll do a video for that
next and then obviously doctor strange 2 is out
in theaters this week all my easter eggs post
credit scene videos bonus videos for the movie
will start posting in the next couple of days as
it does come out in theaters everyone click here
for that non-spoilery doctor strange 2 review
and click here for that obi-wan kenobi trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!